pleased to have here on the rich eisen
show for the first time uh the star of
bosch if you watch something on amazon
prime it's uh
because this show was a hit from the
very beginning
and the seventh and final season of
bosch premieres
this coming friday on amazon prime video
the actor titus wellever here on the
rich eisen show how are you sir
i'm well how are you doing i'm doing
fine big fan of yours thanks for calling
in i appreciate it
well thank you for having me man i
appreciate it absolutely
did you have any uh sense of
how successful this show could be
certainly when
it's on a streamer that really wasn't
doing very much
at the time what was that like for you
to start this show
titus well it was i mean it was a it was
a whole brave new world
in that regard had no idea what to
you know to anticipate uh you know my
hope was
that it it would succeed um
and then it would you know find its
audience i mean that being said i think
you know truth be known our our show is
based on
a series of you know hugely successful
um novels written by michael connolly um
you know global um
um audience and uh
you know it was my hope but you know you
never know particularly when you have a
uh uh you know it's a literary source
you know people are
they have their own kind of prejudice
and it was you know
very very possible that people were
going to say
i'm not going to watch that it's you
know yeah i i do the same thing i read a
book and then
somebody says oh they're making a film
out of that and then you know
they you see who's cast and you go oh i
don't want to watch that
it's going to be it's going to be a
train wreck so fortunately
um and i ran the risk of that people
were saying oh it must be intimidating
and i thought
you know there's nothing i can do but do
my job which is to try to play harry
bosch
the bosch of the books and either people
will accept it or they won't
so fortunately they did but yeah it was
a whole new
idea and and i was uh i was not familiar
with it i mean i really didn't even i
didn't even have
netflix or any streaming services at
that point
i didn't i didn't i got a smart tv and i
told them not to hook up anything
because it scared me
because you don't want to have somebody
walking around and somebody walking
around knowing what your
your purchasing power is just through
your television shows but i mean
look we're we're sitting here on peacock
right now on a streamer
and um and 10 years ago
uh or i guess eight years ago 2013
i mean when you're saying hey i'm doing
a tv show for amazon where people are
saying like well that's where i get my
stuff
i mean you had to probably explain to
your friends or maybe have
explained to you what the heck that was
all about when you were starting this
program off
i did 100 and they were you know
now what amazon did was they didn't just
come out of the box with one thing i
mean we were there
their drama but they came out with um
you know options uh of programming and
kind of
you know it was a springboard from there
um
so they they were prepared but yeah uh
yeah there were there were a lot of
people
who were kind of but you know everything
was kind of happening all at once you
had
you know as amazon was there was the
time but they were really at the ground
floor and then you had apple tv
and um you know and netflix and hulu and
roku and um and you know now you have
peacock and hbo max
and um you know disney plus
and which for a guy like me
is fantastic um because
i i will uh i will literally
um stay in my pajamas the entire day and
just
binge watch episodes of the six million
dollar man
[Music]
[Laughter]
i and i i i cheers you for that i tipped
my figurative cap for you on that titus
well
i thought you were gonna say that
because you're you're invariably on
something somewhere
uh on some streamer somewhere whether
it's deadwood or
um you know gone baby gone or brooklyn
south or
you know repeat of nypd blue sons of
anarchy i mean
that's what i thought you meant that
it's good for you because invariably
somewhere somebody's streaming something
you're doing
you know and i'm not getting paid a cent
for it but um
wow i have really stepped on something
right there i stepped in it
well at least hold on a second hold on a
second do you do you at least get a free
amazon prime card
do you at least get this i don't what
the hell every my friends all said that
in the beginning they went oh so now you
have free prime and i went no
[Laughter]
so i guess anything i learned look you
know what i mean
uh the uh um i did learn
that and i you know i i'm not dissimilar
to my father i mean with my kids i've
always been
open the door in the morning and i'm
like go outside and play and do things
and
don't come back unless you have to go to
the bathroom or you need a drink of
water or you're hungry
and you know then there's me now you
know and i've always been
that guy and then all of a sudden you
know i'm saying to my kids where are you
going
oh you know you know dad the world's
open up and i'm going to go and have
lunch with my friends
but there's a bionic woman marathon
the old lindsay wagner defense i like it
um i i like that
i like that you know titus it's funny
i've got a 12 a 10 and a seven year old
and we're the same way trying to my wife
and i trying to get him off the screen
and my 12 year old right now sometimes
we catch him watching the worst crap
on youtube where it's just somebody who
invariably does admittedly have like 30
million followers
and all they do is just sit there and
they get all these videos from somebody
else's phones
and just say the snarkiest stuff and
they're watching this garbage and i'm
like get the hell off of youtube
and my 12 year old son says dad the rich
eisen shows all over youtube what's your
problem
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i'm like i don't uh have quite an
answer for that sort of thing
i said but at least my show's not crap
that's what's that's my response
that's what i said no but that's the i
know
you know what my my kids are are are 15
19 and 22. and i you know my 15 year old
i don't want to say that she goes down
that rabbit hole but every now and then
you know this tick tock thing and stuff
like that i go i
wanna but then i you know then i find
myself
you know sounding like you know what i
was urinating you know uh
you know but i raised my kids because i
didn't like
spongebob squarepants and the offerings
that were out there when my kids were
little so
i i went out and if i couldn't find it
in the store i would go on ebay and so
my kids were raised on
johnny quest and the six million dollar
man i know i'm glad i keep
it's i'm not friends with lee major
[Laughter]
but all this like rap patrol time tunnel
lost in space no i i
uh with my kids i would just say look
app troop you know
nice anything that i could get my hands
on because i i would look at the stuff
that they were watching on some of these
kids channels and i would go it's crap
crap it's late it's not even good
it's not even good titus well over here
on the rich eisen show so when did you
show your kids deadwood
when did that happen oh they kind of
came
at that on their own i walked in
on my uh my middle child quinn when he
was
i uh he was he was way too young to be
looking at it but he got curious and
popped in
and i walked in and it was you know you
know they
we were feeding the pig to you know
feeding the guy to lose pigs or
something
and he was like daddy look you're on tv
and i went oh my god
yeah you know catching your kid with a
playboy magazine i was like no you're
not ready for that
[Laughter]
yeah that that that's one thing for sure
so
uh i i just know i'm such a huge fan of
that show
uh what was it like working on it
because i can
i sometimes had to watch a show two
three times to understand it i'm
wondering what it was like to read the
script and then have to learn those
lines and like
the most profane iambic pentameter you
know and
and um what was that like for you
to be with the stars there as well and
whatnot titus you gotta go
you know it's really exciting and that
was uh i had done several other
television series with david milch and
this was a
talk about you know stepping out of your
wheelhouse and your comfort zone
and i came in at the very end of the
first season
and uh you know david has a process and
in his writing you know we would
there would be sort of summaries of what
was to come but a lot of the
um scenes were written um
you know the day of or the night before
and so uh
you know that's a very difficult
dialogue to learn
under any circumstances to get it uh
very kind of last minute um there's a
whole other
set of challenges but it's david milch
and nobody
nobody writes like he does and so it was
a huge gift and obviously
um an amazing ensemble
of actors um and uh you know 99
of my stuff that i did on that show was
with ian mcshane so that
gosh in itself was um
[Music]
was amazing and he you know ian is one
of the most
um you know people go like oh you must
have been terrified and
and how intimidating and i said you know
actually no because ian is the
most generous actor on the planet and
he's also
a he's hilariously funny yeah
and is an amazing storyteller but um
just to be in his presence and to watch
him
parse a scene knowing that he would have
gotten you know
the curly facts pages at one o'clock in
the morning the night before
and then you know you're
sitting in a room with him where he's
doing you know four pages of dialogue
where you've got a small interjection
here and there and it's you know
it's something to behold i mean it's
that one thing where you go
wow now you get to see uh an actor
operating and firing on all
cylinders and it's and then it surpasses
any kind of
um you know idea or or or fantasy of
what it
could be but you're in the presence of
it and you get to witness it it was just
an amazing experience and a very
close-knit group of people
very very tight ensemble and it was a
you know it was a wonderful
wonderful experience and i i think i
ever everybody
who was involved would say you know when
you work with david milch
it makes you a better actor and um
and so that experience is invaluable
titus well over here on the rich eisen
show bosch
season seventh and final season of bosch
premiering on
amazon prime video uh this coming friday
uh i couldn't help but notice you've
been in every single uh
ben affleck directed film how did you
guys tie it or is that you're from
connecticut is that a new england thing
or what what is it
what what's your connection there with
ben you know i
or i auditioned for gone baby gone
uh reluctantly because the the
the breakdown description of the
character was uh a character that was
uh 10 to 15 years older than i was
i was shooting deadwood at the time so i
had hair down
to my shoulders and a beard to the
middle of my chest
and um so i thought i'm not going to get
this part but it was
you know i just thought well why not i
read the script and the script was
amazing so i went in and
because i i lived uh in
boston and lived in maine went to
boarding school in maine i
i knew the dialect i knew i kind of knew
the world at these characters
lived in um and i just uh kind of gave
it my all and then was very lucky that
uh
um that ben cast me and that and he and
i
got on he's without question one of the
best directors i've ever worked with and
he's uh he's a
he's an excellent uh uh actor
and uh a great writer and he's also just
a very very
good human being and
very very prepared um
has every single shot in his head um
and i uh i feel really really privileged
to have
been there you know on the ground floor
when he did gone baby gone
and to be there in the in his
progression
you know as evolution as a as a director
um we already knew he was a great actor
and a writer before he ever directed
um but um you know a great privilege and
uh an exciting place to be and work with
and i love working with him and i'm you
know i'm waiting for him to
to call me up and say let's go do
something else again or
or if i have to i'll go and ring his
door balancing
hire me so uh you spending all that time
in boston is it safe to say then you're
a red sox fan that was strolling around
fenway park at the end of the town
or or is that a safe yeah yeah 100
i mean um you know that's one of the
things of
you know because i'm you know i'm really
a new yorker philly guy but i spent
a lot of formulative time up in
in boston and in maine going to have
gone to high school there
um in boarding school and
uh being there at a time when
you know the teams weren't doing all
that well uh the bruins were doing
great but you know the red sox were kind
of slumpy and
um uh although the celtics then being
there late
you know in the hole when when bird came
the the you know those are the those are
the great
the great years and and and that part of
the franchise with bird and the whole
thing
you know with magic and that rivalry and
that's basketball was a whole different
level
um but i enjoy sports so i'm you know
people say to me well
and i'm of a generation where you could
like
uh players from different teams now
everybody's like choose a side choose a
side
and i say to my kids don't listen to
that you know um
you know i can remember as a kid you
know
that i liked all the different
quarterbacks some teams you know roman
gabriel and joe cap and fran tarkington
and you're like oh
gail sarah's plays for the bears and
dick buckes is for the bears but
it was cool you could you could one day
wear a bear's jersey
and the next day where a philadelphia
eagles jersey or an la rams
and nobody would get in your kitchen
about it nowadays
yeah that's a different story i wear a
red sox hat here
people are you know spitting at me um
but but i go to a dodgers game if i go
to a dodgers game
i'm wearing my dodgers hat so right you
know and i'm from the east coast and you
know i always made fun of dodgers fans
uh getting there late and leaving early
but now i'm definitely one of those
there's no question about it
i'll be on east coast like look at these
people showing up second inning and
leaving in the seventh and right now if
they if the game's like out of reach in
the sixth
i am out the door i'm yanking my kids
out of there so fast it's not even fun
no i know because
yeah you get you know you gotta consider
parking yes forget it
exactly titus uh this has been a blast
man uh congrats on uh the final season
uh of bosch but there is a spin-off
series coming correct that's
that's that's true tell me tell me about
that
so well you know we where we leave off
uh we have a bit of an easter egg and
there is a setup at the end of this
okay season seven uh which kind of um
is the connective tissue it paves the
way um
for the new show which is is being
touted as a spin-off but
you know truth be known it's really it's
a continuation
um it's just not uh you know with harry
being in the hollywood station anymore
um and uh so it's it's
uh harry bosch and matty bosh and money
chandler
and you know their stories are all are
all linked
but there's also a kind of um uh
autonomy
at the same at the same time with with
storyline so i think it's uh you know
it's a continuing
uh part of the telling of of the bosch
you know universe and uh i'm sure we'll
pepper that universe
periodically with with cameos um
from the characters from the original
show but i
i i shy from calling it a spin-off and
more really a continuation and
excellent it's set up so i'm i'm excited
for
for this season to come out and i think
now the uh
the fun part the the gift of it will be
when people get to the end
and they see the easter egg they'll go
oh okay
and it will it will light the fire for
them to um
you know want to come back and not feel
like they're going to be disappointed
because
you know harry's wearing an ascot
and gucci loafers that's not going to
happen
he's still the same guy titus this has
been a blast uh i'd love to have you in
studio i mean we didn't even hit david
lynch or steven bochko or any of the
people from your past i mean we're big
pop culture nuts here and uh we we do
have um
uh certainly i'd love you in studio
because we have a deadwood hat here
that's been signed by uh anybody who's
been in deadwood that's been here in
studio from timothy oliphant ian mcshane
uh garrett dillahunt w o brown kristen
bell everybody signs it with their
favorite curse word that they said on
the show
so i need you i need to add you to this
mix well we'll make that happen thank
you titus i appreciate it congrats on
the final season uh hitting uh amazon
streamers on friday and let's chat down
the road please
thank you very much you guys have a
great day right back at you what a blast
at wellever underscore titus on twitter
at tituswelloverofficial on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here